the covariance between two random
variables tells us something about the
strength of the dependence between them
but it is not so easy to interpret
qualitatively for example if I tell you
that the covariance of x and y is equal
to 5 this does not tell you very much
about whether x and y are closely
related or not another difficulty is
that if x and y are in units let's say
of meters then the covariance will have
units of meters squared and this is hard
to interpret a much more informative
quantity is the so called correlation
coefficient which is a dimensionless
version of the covariance it is defined
by this formula here we just take the
covariance and divide it by the product
of the standard deviations of the two
random variables now if X has units of
meters then the standard deviation also
has units of meters and so this ratio
will be dimensionless and it is not
affected by the units that were using
the same is true for this ratio here and
this is why the correlation coefficient
does not have any units of its own one
remark if we're dealing with the random
variable whose standard deviation is
equal to zero so its variance is also
equal to zero then we have a random
variable which is identically equal to a
constant well for such cases of the
general random variables then the
correlation coefficient is not defined
because it would have involved a
division by zero a very important
property of the correlation coefficient
is the following it turns out that the
correlation coefficient is always
between minus 1 and 1 and this allows us
to judge whether a certain correlation
coefficient is big or not because we now
have an absolute scale and so it does
provide a measure of the degree to which
two random variables are associated to
interpret the correlation coefficient
let us now look at some extreme cases
suppose that
and why are independent in that case we
know that the covariance is going to be
equal to zero and therefore the
correlation coefficient is also going to
be equal to zero and in that case we say
that the two random variables are
uncorrelated however the converse
statement is not true we have seen
already an example in which we have zero
covariance and therefore zero
correlation but yet the two random
variables were dependent let us now look
at the other extreme where the two
random variables are as dependent as
they can be so let's look at the
correlation coefficient of one random
variable with itself what is it going to
be well the covariance of a random
variable with itself is just the
variance of that random variable now
Sigma X is going to be the same as Sigma
Y because we are taking Y to be the same
as X so we're dividing by Sigma x
squared but the square of the standard
deviation is the variance so we obtain a
value of one so a correlation
coefficient of one shows up in such a
case of an extreme dependence if instead
we had taken the correlation coefficient
of X with the negative of X in that case
we would have obtained a correlation
coefficient of minus one in somewhat
more general situation that the one we
considered here is the following if we
have two random variables that have a
linear relation that is if I know why I
can figure out the value of x with
absolute certainty and they can figure
it out by using a linear formula in this
case it turns out that the correlation
coefficient is either plus 1 or minus 1
and the converse is true if the
correlation coefficient has absolute
value of 1 then the two random variables
obey a deterministic linear relation
between them so to conclude an extreme
value for the correlation coefficient of
plus or minus
one is equivalent to having a
deterministic relation between the two
random variables involved a final remark
about the algebraic properties of the
correlation coefficient what can we say
about the correlation coefficient of a
linear function of a random variable
with another well we already know
something about what happens to the
covariance when we form a linear
function and the covariance of AX plus B
with Y is related this way to the
covariance of X with Y now let us use
this property and calculate the
correlation coefficient between ax plus
B and Y in the numerator we have the
covariance of AX plus B with Y which is
equal to a times the covariance of X
with Y at the denominator we have the
standard deviation of this random
variable now the standard deviation of
this random variable is equal to a times
the standard deviation of X if a is
positive if a is negative then we need
to put a minus sign but in either case
we will have here the absolute value of
a time's the standard deviation of X and
then we divide by the standard deviation
of the second random variable which is y
and so what we obtain here is this ratio
which is a correlation coefficient of x
with y times this quantity which is the
sine of a so we have the sine of a
time's the correlation coefficient of X
with Y so in particular the magnitude of
the correlation coefficient is not going
to change when we replace X by ax plus B
and this essentially means that if we
change the units of the random variable
X for example suppose that X was degrees
Celsius and ax plus B is degrees
Fahrenheit going from one set of units
Celsius degrees to another set of units
degrees in Fahrenheit is not going to
change the correlation coefficient of
the temperature with some other random
variable so this is a nice property of
the correlation coefficient again which
reflects the fact that it's dimensions
less it doesn't have any units of its
own and it doesn't depend on what kinds
of Units we use for each one of the
random variables